the next program we have in our hand
is
is focused on transcriptomics data
analysis for chronic diseases and uh
this in this program we will discuss
various aspects of transcriptomic data
analysis which is also called as rna-seq
data analysis and how
this specific field of bioinformatics
has evolved and continued to evolve to
help us understand the disease biology
or systems biology from the disease of
disease biology from the systems aspect
biology aspect so the technique and the
analysis methods and
and
bioinformatics analysis for
understanding the patterns within the
data and the comparative analysis of
this data has evolved and has been
defined over the years now it is at a
point where
all of these data analysis can be run
without or with minimal user inter
intervention
and it is now regularly used by many
scientists and
and has been performed um
used for in-depth analysis of gene
expression data and isoform expression
data to study the transcriptomic
landscape of the diseased state or
altered state etc so um
so we know that the genomics data has
provided genomics and
transcriptomic data has provided new
ways and new options and new dimensions
to link targets to disease and how to
validate these targets the result of
this
genomics data revolution is is the
potential for a new era of drug
discovery and transcriptomics is at the
right right
at the pedestal for those drug discovery
um discovery of the drugs that control
disease through uh regulating gene
expression for example or by mimicking
mimicking the mechanisms by which our
body exits control over a range of
normal and disease functions so
the
the underlying data that is required for
performing a transcriptomic data
analysis as you would have guessed comes
from next generation sequencing and
let's talk about ngs and what it
represents in transcriptomics data
compared to the other techniques and
also get a brief introduction to how
traditionally
mrna abundance or express gene gene
expression abundance has been measured
quickly so uh
so as a method of measuring rna
translation transcriptomics
studies actually help us to detect mrna
expression inside the cell and this mrna
expression will act as an accurate
alternative to
alternative or accurate proxy to the
conditions of the cell that it
represents so this conditions and this
phenotypic this transcriptomics
landscape or expression landscape
can can help us to help us understand um
for example
the disease biology or the development
of resistance for a particular treatment
or generally the difference in in the
molecular pathways and difference in the
biological function that that ah one set
of tissues uh
establish or one set of tissues um
excerpt over i mean compared to the
other set of tissues so at the forefront
or at the basic level we have to measure
the mrna level or the amount of mrna
present in the cells
present in the
tissues so how do we do that
traditionally this has been done using
microarray technologies more about this
and comparing and contrasting
microarrays and ngs are detailed in this
program but
with each and every iterations
or reach development in technology
involved in measuring the
mrna abundance we
get more and more data on more and more
information
regarding
uh regarding the
cell or regarding the phenotype of
disease biology of the cell so i in the
end what we would like to have is
something like uh something like this
where the genes and the isoforms of the
genes will actually represent the
difference in the type of samples or
difference in the phenotype of the
samples that it that it is taken from so
depending upon your analysis methods
depending upon your type of question you
can either go for traditionally
understanding or analyzing the gene
expression landscape or you can go for
isoform expression landscape where you
will get your hands on or where you will
get information about the uh alternative
splice forms of the genes that you are
analyzing
so this yeah as we said this yeah this
this will uh extending your analysis
method to include iso forms will
actually help you uh understand or help
you
um
identify some unannotated
exons or novel transcripts which have
not been characterized before so that
can be very crucial in understanding the
disease biology
so these patterns and gene expression
patterns and transcriptomic landscape
can be uh can help you identify or help
you help you understand the biological
markers or bio markers uh for which is
always used for um
which is uh used to uh
used in the clinical data diagnostics
and clinical therapy selection selection
of different therapies and improvement
of clinical diagnosis so uh
uh
more and more of these data and more and
more new discoveries based on these
expression patterns and isothermic
expression patterns will help us
understand these complex diseases at the
subcellular level also from the
target identification for the new or
repurposing of existing drugs or novel
drug design
so
these this is transcriptomics program
and this program includes six or seven
interactive session we will cover all
these topics within this interactive
session in addition to this you will get
a practical hands-on where um
you will get yeah you will understand
the logic behind setting up this
transcriptomics data analysis which we
will discuss in detail i will go rush a
little bit for yeah i will rush a little
bit quickly here and
in the end of this analysis you will get
a list of uh output files which you can
either explore them interactive
or download them to uh use it for your
report or use it in your analysis
using your analysis so in addition to
identifying differentially expressed
genes which is a which is a which is
which is the aim of performing
transcriptomic data analysis you can
also understand how different ah
different pathways are enriched or
suppressed
because of the
genes that are differentially expressed
in the conditions that we are
analyzing or comparing
so yeah the basic this this we will this
i will skip and the outputs are
you will get a myriad or variety of
outputs which will include tables which
will include the plots and which will
include um
which will also include visual uh output
interactive visual output so all of this
will help you understand the biological
phenomena or clinical consultation of
the disease
so
as i mentioned this uh as i mentioned
this structured data can be used for
further data science based uh analysis
and yeah this we already discussed so we
we will skip so you also get an
introduction to single cell
transcriptomics which is uh
you also get an introduction to singles
and transcriptomics which uh which can
help us understand uh all the messenger
rnas that are present in single cell
resolution so it is not like bulk cell
profiling which we have been discussing
so far where the sequence libraries are
created for uh for an average mrna
expression quantification for a
different uh for for a tissue here you
will get the tissue composition at the
single cell resolution let's quickly
skip through a couple of these parts we
have one more program to cover so this
actually tells the power of single cell
analysis
pipeline analysis where you can for
example here where you can get
different
cell types that populate a tissue so
that you can understand the
heterogeneity behind the tissue that you
are analyzing in a much more uh clear
fashion so this level of resolution you
will not obtain or you will not get from
bulk cell rna analysis
a bulcell rna analysis and single cell
rna analysis
complements the balsa rna
understanding of the disease biology in
a very
upcoming under normal fashion